nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15
off go to nebia.com pacman and use the
code
pacman all right let's jump right in um
a lot of today's show is going to be
essentially getting ourselves caught up
and framed in terms of the state of the
republican party right now and
while some of you may think this this
has everything to do with trump it
doesn't it has some to do with trump and
it has a lot to do
uh with some of the developing factions
in the republican party but also just
the fundamental
kind of empirical problems that need to
be solved before
if and before the republican party would
be able to participate in any meaningful
political policy and scientific
discussion and
th this i may be sort of not clear in
what i'm talking about but to begin with
let's start with part of the problem
with scientific framing in the
republican party we have a new poll out
now from economist yougov
which shows that republicans
trust on medical issues
donald trump over dr anthony fauci
over the cdc and maybe not surprisingly
over the biden administration that one
maybe would be to be expected but
um uh less indicative of a problem
then is the lack of trust in dr fauci
and the cdc the vast majority of
republicans
surveyed say they trust donald trump
on medical advice despite the fact that
he wondered about
injecting bleach disinfectants
etc 66 percent
of self-identified republicans say they
trust
trump a lot or somewhat for medical
advice
only 11 percent of republicans trust joe
biden now
that's less of an obvious problem to me
in the sense that
they're both politicians now of course
you and i would look at that and say
well but joe biden's positions are just
repeating what doctors say whereas
trumps have been
arguing against doctors no doubt about
it but
it's less concerning than when you
compare to dr fauci
and the cdc um you look at
uh 20 the cdc had the highest level of
trust at 57
overall uh dr anthony fauci had
48 percent trust overall but
when you look specifically at
republicans republicans
trust trump more than fouchy and also
more
than the cdc so why do i care about this
it's not because i want to go and make
fun of trumpists who
trust trump over dr fauci i really don't
care many of them believe lots of things
that aren't true
and it doesn't really matter in terms of
the political discourse or in making
specific things happen they just have
different beliefs and we just sort of
write it off
here it has a very practical life and
death implication when you
think back to the start of the pandemic
and you look at the disastrous u.s
response
much of what we see today is as a result
of that when donald trump and
republicans
i don't know if pretended or lied or
whatever didn't know
all along how serious this was and
the masked discussion where they were
against masks
and the guidelines discussion where they
were against guidelines the open
everything people
and then of course as we got into the
vaccine era if for a year you've been
told this isn't really serious and you
don't need to do anything of course
you're going to be less likely to want a
vaccine why would you need a vaccine for
something you've been told for a year
isn't serious anyway and then the
conspiracies and then the bill gates
um rfid chip vaccinations or whatever
the case may be
this has very real world implications
and when you now look at the numbers and
you look at
uh i mean could there be more
dramatically different
vaccine situations than for example
mississippi and massachusetts to pick
two states that start with the letter m
uh widely reporting in mississippi
tens of thousands of vaccination
appointments
that no one's showing up to they're
trying to figure out in mississippi what
do we do
because we have all these locations we
have all these appointments available we
have all the
this vaccine and people aren't signing
up
compared to a state like massachusetts
where 92 percent
of the population says that they want
the vaccine massachusetts reportedly 30
days away
from herd immunity very different
situation in mississippi while it's warm
or warming while we are seeing a decline
of cases
um okay maybe you're not going to see
dramatically different situations
when if indeed this becomes seasonal and
we start to see another uptick in the
fall
you're going to see another two-tiered
system from states with herd immunity
and states that completely lack it so
when when you see a poll
and it says these republicans trust
trump
more than fouchy or the cdc it is easy
to just laugh it off and say look at
these stupid people
but it affects everybody uh as we know
not everybody can get vaccinated
children won't be able to get vaccinated
for some time we still don't know how
long hopefully 12 to 16
and 12 to 18 very soon you know 8 to 12
is going to take longer etc
uh this has a real world impact and uh
when you
uh when you trust trump over fouchy it
follows perfectly logically
that republicans would be trump
supporting republicans would be the most
anti-vaccine group in the united states
at this point in time how do you change
this i don't know
we have seen the anti-vac sentiment
decline
the number of people who want the
vaccine has gone up
one idea from from a couple of weeks ago
was
maybe if there are more uh pastors and
clergy that are saying get the vaccine
as a religious duty
uh the vaccine you know p buddha judge
saying over the weekend
um uh god allowed the vaccine the
vaccine exists in the context of god
imagine
god you know if the vaccine was really
bad god would have prevented it or
something like that
makes no sense to me based on my
sensibilities maybe that would work
in uh at least getting more religious
republicans to be interested in the
vaccine i don't know what the answer is
but the point is
the this has real world impact we talk
sometimes about flat earth as a
relatively benign conspiracy theory
you can make the case with flat earth
that often flat earthers believe lots of
other stuff that is damaging you've got
a lot of overlap between flat earthers
and um uh other types of conspiracy
theorists anti-anti-semitic conspiracy
theorists
um you know one world government type
stuff
by itself flat earth as a belief is not
damaging in the same way that the
false beliefs about the pandemic are
and we're seeing that translate in very
real terms these people trust trump over
fouchy
and they are one of the most
anti-vaccine groups how do we fix it i
don't know
what i do know big picture
is that placating the anti-vaxx beliefs
is not the way forward
and speaking of placating and
negotiating with terrorists
we have to talk next about joe manchin
shortly after joe biden won and it
looked like control of the u.s senate
was going to come down
to two seats in georgia we knew that the
best case scenario was
50 50 with democrats technically having
a majority
because kamala harris gets to cast the
tie-breaking
51st vote if all 50 democrats are on the
same page
about a particular issue or bill or
whatever the case may be and so
when we knew that that was going to be
the scenario i started talking about joe
manchin
and as the most conservative democratic
senator in the u.s senate i said back in
november december joe manchin could be a
formidable impediment to joe biden
getting things done that he claims that
he wants
to do and my audience was split some in
my audience
understood the magnitude of it they
understood why i was talking about joe
manchin
some denied it and said nah joe
manchin's not going to really be that
big of an obstacle
as we are clearly seeing now with joe
manchin
opposed to so much of what joe biden
wants to do
we realize that he is indeed
a formidable obstacle and now on top of
this we're learning something
about why and it's absolutely horrifying
in an interview with cnn over the
weekend
senator joe manchin straight up says the
january 6th
trump riots made him realize
that we need bipartisanship and we need
to placate
the rioters wait what
he correctly says in this clip that i'm
going to play for you
that he was shocked by the direct
attack on the basic institutions of
government and democracy on january 6th
as we all
should have been and many of us were but
joe manchin says it made him decide
he needs to seek bipartisanship period
he can't just go
along with whatever joe biden wants to
do the violence
and what is essentially uh the the
terrorism
the hostage-taking it worked in exactly
the way
that the terrorists wanted he is saying
when terrorists hold me hostage i
negotiate with them
listen to him and then we're going to
talk about it more january 6 changed me
and i was very clear with everybody
i never thought in my life i never read
in history books
to where our form of government had been
attacked
at our seat of government which is
washington dc at our capital
by our own people now the british did it
but not americans
so something told me wait a minute pause
hit the pause button something's
wrong you can't have this many people
split to where they want to go to war
with each other can you imagine
joe manchin now stands in the way of
much of what joe biden wants to do
because he wants bipartisanship
thanks to people who stormed the capital
and did violence
and committed crimes and wanted the
loser uh donald trump to be installed as
president right that's what they wanted
completely anti-democratic completely
against the law completely against
everything the country supposedly stands
for
whether joe manchin intends to or not
whether joe manchin realizes it or not
he is encouraging them to do it again
the reaction
to the violent riots should not be you
know that really shocked me
that they were willing to do that so i'm
going to be
more bipartisan and play to their side
so that we don't have as big of a
disagreement in this country between
right and left that's the wrong reaction
he is playing to those who rioted saying
i will now vote in the senate
in a different way that will be closer
to what those who rioted want the
reaction should be
those who rioted should be held
accountable there should be consequences
rather than
rewards he's talking about rewarding
them we must not
give the impression that what they did
on january 6th
is valid political speech or activism if
you do what they did on january 6th
they should get nothing from joe manchin
or anybody you should be
invalidating voices that use crime
to get their points across and yet joe
manchin is saying
you know the writers made me realize
we're too divided so
you know i'm not going to go with stuff
joe biden wants if there isn't
republican support
what what he he wants to bridge the gap
between the rioters and the non-rioters
give me a break joe
the primary takeaway from january 6th
is that we have to protect the country
from the influence of people who are
willing to do what the rioters did
we should be giving them no role in
policy or governance whatsoever
not to cater to them this is backwards
logic from joe it's not even logic quite
frank i don't know why
it's it's there's no logic here it
changed him
he says apparently for the worse they
intimidated him
and it worked he should be recommitting
to only consider the ideas of
non-rioters it's a completely bizarre
argument and reaction they were trying
to kill him
and his reaction is let me let me give
them more of what they want
after 9 11 should we have said you know
we maybe we should look at giving al
qaeda some stuff
i don't know i mean they were really
angry and so they did 9 11.
maybe that anger means we should give
them some stuff it's backwards
it's backwards so that's joe manchin
giving us now a framework we've been
wondering you know what is it with joe
manchin
this is we now understand the framework
under which joe manchin is operating in
the senate
i don't know how you work with a guy
like that and
um yeah i know that we often have this
debate well just primary joe manchin and
like put bernie sanders in
i don't think bernie sanders wins in
west virginia
i think you just get a republican it's
about we have to look at
other places i mean sure primary mansion
if you want
if you successfully do it might lead to
a republican but at the same time
we have to be looking at states races in
which in 2022
a republican senator can be removed and
a democratic senator can be put in
hopefully one
who is more reliable uh vote
than uh joe manchin has been let me know
what you think
this strikes me as could not possibly be
more backwards find me on twitter at
deepakman
let me know your thoughts one of our
sponsors today is
nebia the creator of the world's most
innovative
shower head it uses only about half
the water that other shower heads do
saving you money helping the environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it
only took a few minutes to set up really
easy and it's been a totally different
experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about half
as much
water nebia also offers a number of
shower accessories like shelves and
curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia.com
pacman and use code pacman will get 15
percent off
all nebia products remember that our
show is mostly funded by
individual members you can grab a
membership at jointpakman.com get the
daily bonus show
get all of the other great perks
including commercial free audio
and video streams of the show all of
that great stuff
at joinpackman.com we are going to be
talking about a number of aspects of a
weekend republican donor event that took
place
at donald trump's florida club doral
looks like doral to me i don't know why
they say doral but if that's what they
say i'll say it it took place this
weekend we're going to talk
yes about what donald trump said but
really the relevance of trump now
is more now that he's out of office the
relevance is
what happens to the followers of trump
in the republican party because they
really are the future of the party
the followers will decide whether it's
trump or someone
else at the head of the party in 2024
and they will decide whether these
trumpian republican officials get
reelected or removed in 2022
and so okay hearing what trump says fine
but hearing from his followers
and from republican donors that's really
the future of the party and it's
unfortunately as bad as anybody could
have imagined
we're going to look at an interview with
a woman that cnn spoke to
in florida at this republican donor
event at which donald trump also spoke
over the weekend
i was looking at this like the zapruder
film i mean you you almost have to go
frame by frame because there is so much
ignorance and delusion and toxicity
packed
into a really small amount of video so
let's just jump right into the first
clip
and uh i do believe that the election
was stolen
and i do believe that it was a peaceful
rally that day and that just because
people who are in the capital were
wearing trump shirts and trump hats
doesn't necessarily make them trump
supporters
anybody can get one of those shirts so
that is merely
18 seconds and it is filled
with ignorance that could take months to
overcome
and change people's minds about i do
believe the election was stolen she says
she's not a lone nut
i mean she's a nut but she's not a lone
nut because
sixty percent of republicans believe
exactly that
sixty percent of republicans believe
that donald trump was the rightful
winner of the november 2020 election now
december january february march april
we're we're now five months out
60 of them still believe that okay that
is not a fringe view
there are you could have tens of
millions of conversations
just like this one with other trump
voters
she says the trump riots were mostly
peaceful
and not really trump supporters half of
republicans believe that
and the reporter tries to explain we
know that they were trump supporters
there is no doubt when
when we look at the court cases we find
you know years of pro-trump social media
activity
at some point you have to apply occam's
razor did they two years ago
three years ago five years ago knowing
on january 6
they were going to pretend to be
trumpists start falsely
seeding s-e-e-d
false pro-trump stuff on their social
media or if it walks like a duck and it
sounds like a duck it's simply a duck
and she doesn't care when she's
presented with that take a listen
but a lot of them have been shown to be
real trump supporters right through
indictments that they've been a long
long time support of trump
i don't know that to be true so this is
really a case of burden of proof
she believes without evidence that the
trumpists at the riots were fake trump
supporters there's no evidence of that
there is evidence that they are real
trump supporters
but she hasn't seen it so she dismisses
it out of hand
this is a really big epistemological
hurdle to clear and we've talked about
it before
um very very difficult and the most
effective way is
you build a rapport with this person and
over a period of months
you can maybe get them to change their
view that doesn't work when it's 75
million people that believe this stuff
it's just just a fact of of math quite
frankly
let's continue i think some people will
watch this who are not trump supporters
and they'll say here's a trump supporter
who's in denial about january 6 would it
not be better to
sort of have to say that to me because
i've had friends and family already say
that to me you know because they
disagree they think that
i'm crazy that i'm a conspiracy theorist
because the election was stolen
now that is fascinating she says forget
about
your audience saying i'm in denial my
family and
friends has already been telling me that
for months and yet
it seems to only further her belief that
she is correct this goes back to another
principle we've talked about
uh oftentimes when people are you know
kind of bashed over the head with facts
they don't change their mind they
further
attach or or align themselves to their
beliefs
when they are told by others that's
crazy
they don't say well maybe it is they
further
plant their feet in those beliefs and um
and and that uh it simply doesn't work
as we've talked about before let's look
at more of this
speaking of of your family calling you
conspiracy theorists
uh marjorie taylor green is going to be
speaking here this weekend
she's known as the by some as the q anon
congresswoman
i don't know what's so terrible but
terrible about q anon can you tell me
it's a basis conspiracy theory
well what so you know what is so
terrible about conspiracy theories
anyway can you tell me i mean there's
there was
there were conspiracy theories behind
jfk's assassination i'm old enough to
remember
all the conspiracy theories that swirled
around his assassination
it's always it's always painted in such
a negative
way these conspiracy theories are are
cutting into the foundation of american
democracy are helping inspire
a violent insurrection no
i don't believe that's the case in what
way can you explain
the lie the election was stolen well see
that's
where we part ways i don't believe that
it's a lie
i just love that you you actually see
if you're watching how she seems to be
back on the defensive for a moment there
but then she comes up with something
that in some republican circles is what
i call
faux enlightened f-a-u-x faux
enlightened
you can always these are crutches these
are
i wouldn't even call them
epistemological crutches because there's
no epistemology there
it's a rhetorical crutch where you can
always say
what's so bad about x anyway and that
makes you quote open to quote
ideas this is a really common thing
that people on the right who know enough
to know they know that they don't really
have facts
but they also have these rhetorical
crutches they can
put their weight on like turning
something back on
on the other person and then we get to
what is now one of the toughest problems
that we're dealing with
which is disagreements about what facts
are
now i i've made this distinction before
and it's a really important one to
understand
we're not experiencing a disagreement
about what
the facts are we've had that forever
we're having a problem of lots of people
don't know
what type of statement is a statement of
fact and what type of statement is a
statement of opinion much of right-wing
media is built on the fact that their
audience doesn't know the difference
a huge portion of this country
particularly on the american right
doesn't understand that not all
statements can be reduced to we have a
different
set of equally valid beliefs there are
knowable facts and there are opinions
but tons of americans don't know how to
categorize those types of statements
and there's really no easy recovery with
that and i know it's like a broken
record at this point
this goes back to education this goes
back to media literacy critical thinking
stuff you
you really have to start teaching around
age 11 or 12.
um i'm not saying that folks like this
woman
are in a literal sense too far gone but
if you've listened to the phone calls i
get on the show if you've seen the
interviews i do on the show you know
the level of work that would be required
to change one mind for someone that is
so
indoctrinated like this woman imagine 75
million of these people that's why i'm
not optimistic that
these folks are the ones we can
necessarily bring back in bulk
it seems we need to to do a better job
of educating people never to fall for
this stuff in the first place but it's
going to be a very uphill battle
this one's really interesting we have
another example of
occasional voice of reason on fox news
occasional actual journalist on fox news
chris wallace
calling out another republican official
for their just obvious blatant pathetic
hypocrisy
this time the target the victim i don't
know what you would call them the the
mark
is texas republican governor greg abbott
who
said nothing when donald trump was
president about all of the alleged
sexual abuse at migrant shelters when
donald trump was in office
but now all of a sudden that joe biden
is in office greg abbott
is claiming to care about allegations of
sexual assault at these migrant
detention centers so let's get right
into it and then
after this i'll remind you um something
very similar happened with chris wallace
just a couple of weeks ago
we'll look at that a little bit later
here's the clip of chris wallace
and greg abbott let's talk about those
dire consequences you made news this
week reporting that there
are cases of sexual abuse at the
freeman coliseum in san antonio texas
that houses right now more than sixteen
hundred children
but the head of a non-profit that
provides legal services to immigrants
said this
the only reason why abbott is now acting
like he cares about the children
in these facilities is for political
reasons
governor there were thousands of
complaints
of sexual abuse at migrant shelters
during the trump years
not to say that what's going on now is
right but we couldn't find one
instance of you complaining and calling
that out when president trump was
president sure
there are multiple differences between
what happened in the trump
administration and what is happening now
first the trump administration remained
in constant communication
uh with me and with my office and let us
know what was going on
second i saw reports about exactly what
you're talking about
and saw that those reports were filed
with federal agencies
the one that i talked about earlier this
past week
were reports that were filed with state
agencies
the texas health and human services
commission and the department of
protective
and child services which is basically
child protective services
and so we have a duty to respond
to any complaint about child sexual
abuse in texas
as well as to investigate it and that's
exactly what i did
to make sure it was addressed so abbott
says
there are multiple differences when
trump was president
there was really only one difference
which is trump was president then
and joe biden is president now that the
all of the other
differences that uh greg abbott cites
they're really distinctions with no
practical substantive difference and if
it's true
that now greg abbott is being notified
about this
and when it was trump he wasn't being
notified i would look at
whether the reason for that is in itself
politically motivated
every time this happens they always come
up
with meaningless semantic distinctions
that lack any substantive difference and
that's exactly what greg abbott did
now let me remind you the last one of
these that chris wallace did was a
couple of weeks ago
and he interviewed republican senator
tom cotton
and wallace asked tom cotton listen you
know now you're complaining
that with biden's coveted stimulus
prison inmates
received stimulus money they also
got stimulus money during donald trump's
first covet stimulus
and donald trump's second covet stimulus
and you voted for those
and tom cotton came up similarly with a
meaningless response
that has distinctions that really are of
no substantive importance whatsoever
take a look
here is one of your other complaints
about the
the covet relief bill take a look sir
look how crazy some of the democratic
ideas are i mean they had a chance on
saturday morning to stop
checks from going to prisoners from
going to the boston bomber for instance
and on that vote they declined every
single democrat
wanted to continue the practice of
sending checks to prisoners
but senator under two previous coveted
relief bills that you supported and
voted for and that president trump
signed
prisoners also got checks in those bills
well chris that was obviously never
congress's intent the trump
administration irs and treasury
department
did not send checks to prisoners liberal
advocacy groups sued to try to force
that a liberal judge said they had to
last month was the for this month was
the first time we ever had a simple up
or down vote on whether those checks
should go to prisoners
and the simple fact is that every
democrat voted to keep sending checks to
prisoners
i don't think that's a smart idea i
suspect most americans don't either
again
there is no defense other than to say
you know chris that's right i'm playing
politics that's the truth
that's the real answer during covet
stimulus one and two
it wasn't our intent he says but this
time
democrats did want prison inmates to get
the money
and then he says this is the first time
we had an up or down vote and it passed
well that's because you guys controlled
the senate before
and you didn't want an up and down vote
on it but the up and down votes would
have essentially been the same both
times
it's always deflection it's pointing
fingers
and that's really the trump mantra that
a lot of these republicans
have adopted and perfected in some sense
so as far as chris wallace goes
good for him you know we've talked
before wallace tries to find
uh we can all find fault with any cable
news talking head if we want to
i get the impression that chris
wallace's intentions are generally good
that being said there is the
counterpoint
that whether chris is well intentioned
or not
acting in good faith or not his presence
at fox news provides cover a sort of
smoke screen
for people like tucker carlson and sean
hannity and for fox news to say listen
we've got a lot of different things we
have chris wallace and we have tucker
carlson and we have sean hannity
i take the position that it doesn't
matter and what i mean by that is
chris wallace is asking many of the
right questions and sure
he will be used by fox news for fox to
be able to say
we're fair and balanced we have news and
opinion we have things that are more
critical of the
biden administration support whatever
some of these right-wingers will see it
and by math some fraction might realize
wow these republicans are really
hypocrites
and wallace is the exception on fox he's
not the rule i get that
but i continue to believe that his
presence does more good than harm
overall
much like shepherd smith while he lasted
until he ended up just bailing out on
fox news
in terms of abbott and cotton and all of
these guys
they're dangerous they're completely
amoral if not
immoral um greg abbott's lieutenant
governor dan patrick you might remember
was the guy who early in the pandemic
said listen grandma would sacrifice
herself for the economy
by which he meant the stock market so
all of these guys have a very similar
i guess we'd call it a lack of a moral
compass tom cotton never saw
a double standard he could get away from
they're terrible
and any opportunity to possibly expose
them for what they are
even if it's coming during the exception
to the rule on fox news with chris
wallace
i think it's a good thing if you
disagree with me
let me know if you think the presence of
someone like wallace is a net negative
i i'm open to having my mind changed but
you're gonna have to change it let me
know your thoughts
and we'll have more on this and other
such fox news incidents
on our instagram page you can find us on
instagram at david pakman show
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world-famous bonus
show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial-free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the
coupon code better21 all one word
all lowercase become a member today okay
so we're continuing our sort of
uh tour through the modern
april 2021 republican party as it may be
we already looked at an interview with a
republican trump supporter
a republican donor who attended this
very strange event in florida
over the weekend it was an individual
who is experiencing completely unhinged
delusions
and has fallen for baseless conspiracy
theories and is very very secure
in those beliefs so that was that was a
trump supporter
republican donor now let's look at a
little bit of what donald trump said
during his speech to these republican
donors because
if they are to continue their loyalty to
him that we've seen
so far and and the things trump said or
the things that continue being said
heading into 2022
could be an absolute bloodbath for the
republican party and in essence donald
trump's
statements to republican donors over the
weekend can be summarized as
lies conspiracy theories
and absolutely vitriolic rants
including against his own fellow
republicans and that's what makes this
absolutely fascinating for example
donald trump went on the attack over the
weekend
against former republican senate
majority leader
now senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell with the new york times
reporting that donald trump
said the following things and more quote
did he ever say thank you to me talking
about mcconnell
no i hired his wife referring to elaine
chao mitch mcconnell's wife did he ever
say thank you to me
no trump adding that quote a real leader
would not have accepted the result of
the 2020 election
and trump also reportedly according to
three people in the room
referring to mitch mcconnell as a quote
dumb
son of a [ __ ] when trump attacked mitch
mcconnell
the reports are that the room of
republicans really liked it and were
loudly cheering
interesting but what does that mean for
republicans in 2022
trump also went after his own former
vice president mike pence
trump saying to the room full of donors
pence should have had quote
the courage to refuse to certify the
results
understand that trump's gripes with
mcconnell and pence
were that they seemingly realized joe
biden won
and did not humiliate themselves above
and beyond what they did do
in order to try to make that case trump
continued
over the weekend to spread election lies
even telling specific lies about
the results of the 2020 election in
particular states
and said that generally the entire
election was quote
rigged earlier in the show we talked
about how
the republican party voters currently
trust trump on medical issues more than
they trust dr fauci and the cdc one of
the things trump did over the weekend
was
go after dr anthony fauci the crowd
reportedly
loved that applause in the room now why
does this matter
it matters because it's not typical
that the former republican president a
former republican
president spends this much time
attacking his own party
and certainly not as much as he would
spend attacking the other party and
trump did go after joe biden during the
speech
it's all the normal stuff he's been
saying about joe biden it barely
you can imagine what it is it's not
particularly uh relevant or or
notable but republicans always attack
democrats the question for the future of
the republican party is whether they
will
eventually come around to deciding we
are in this to defeat democrats or
whether
this split is going to continue and lead
to chaos and destruction for the party
in 2022
and potentially also in 2024. if they
don't resolve this it has the potential
to be
for me delightfully disastrous for
several
election cycles and this would be this
would be a self-inflicted
uh destruction by the party brought on
by the fact that
for a long time they have been fomenting
non-thinking anti-intellectualism in the
party
okay and understanding the history of
this
matters this trumpian screed over the
weekend
from trump is now many many many layers
removed
of what started during the reagan era
but it did start during the reagan era
and this would sort of be
the just dessert for it uh if you don't
know the history
a very brief outline is that in the
reagan era
the move of the republican party was
towards
a relatively ignorant but still cohesive
and winning strategy which is let's come
out against welfare and lazy people who
are just
living on the dole uh we want personal
responsibility let's be for low taxes
let's be for allowing business to
flourish and
it started to be used to provide cover
for racism and xenophobia that was the
80s under reagan
this appealed to some
pseudo-intellectuals and ignorant people
and people who maybe weren't
paying attention to politics previously
and that got us to the early 1990s
in the early 1990s newt gingrich became
speaker of the house
and he really ushered in like if you
imagine a staircase where at the top
is your party implodes into trumpian
delusion
the second step on that staircase um
is the early 90s newt gingrich becomes
speaker of the house and he plays up the
reactionary
rhetoric he takes another step away from
policy and towards nonsense but there's
still
a bunch of policy with gingrich stuff
about immigration
stuff about health care there's still
policy but they're taking a step towards
uh the the nonsense that we see today
you then get george w bush
george w bush by virtue of being kind of
dim
and completely amoral and having that
texas cowboy personality
appealed even more to the nonsense over
policy
crowd to the rhetoric over substance
crowd
there was still policy it was pretty
base and rudimentary lower taxes that's
good
abortion's bad gay marriage is bad um
you know sending troops around the world
to defend us under the guise of
patriotism that's good
then you get barack obama's presidency
and that really shifts the scale
even more you have a real influx and
focus
on on a ba on the basis of xenophobia
and racism and the non-thinking side of
the republican party
and then the culmination is you have the
perfect electorate in the republican
primary
um to choose someone
like trump um and then
we know you know the rest is history and
so something that was
birthed by the direction the republican
party chose in the 80s
led to trump even though it bears very
little resemblance to it
can it win them 2022 can it win them
2024 i have no idea
it failed in 2018 and it failed in 2020
in those two elections the republican
party lost the house
they lost the senate and they had a
president lose the white house and
become a one-term president maybe it'll
work in 2022
but this is really something they have
to figure out i hope they don't for the
betterment of the country
hey this is really we're going to talk
in the next segment more about matt
gates
donald trump had to be talked out of
publicly defending matt gates now it's
not stopping matt gates from claiming he
has trump support
and we're going to get to that later in
the show but
there's a very interesting report from
cnn and business insider and a number of
different media outlets that donald
trump had to be talked out of
publicly defending republican florida
congressman
matt gates as reports surfaced
almost daily something new and very bad
for matt gates
including questions about whether matt
gates had a sexual relationship with a
minor
whether he actually trafficked that
minor across state lines would
which would be very very bad and maggie
haberman from the new york times
reported on cnn that donald trump wanted
to come out in defense of matt gates
but presumably many of the people around
donald trump were saying
don't say a word these allegations are
really serious
uh haberman said quote his first impulse
was he wanted to defend gates
you know he's one of our people several
of his advisors told him it's a very bad
idea the nature of what gates is being
investigated for is so serious that this
is not something that former president
trump
should be out on a limb for and then
we've seen the silence
from trump world and we now understand
why now again
matt gates is still saying i have trump
support i've heard from trump and it's
all going great
it's not clear whether that's true but
we're going to talk about that
after the break um the
there are some within donald trump's
circle
who actually celebrated the controversy
uh reportedly there are some people
around trump who really don't like matt
gates
and were allegedly gleeful that matt
gates was having them
this problem um a business insider
writes that another trump confidant
echoed the assa sorry echoed the
assessment
um telling politico the reason you
haven't seen people in maga
defending gates is less about him being
unpopular which he is in a lot of
circles
but more about the fact that he hasn't
done a single thing to make people
comfortable to defend him and case in
point
every time gates publicly speaks about
this
scandal um it actually raises new
questions
gates seems to propose
or introduce new potentially derogatory
information about himself
every single time that he does something
publicly he spoke over the weekend at a
very strange event i'll have clips after
the break for you
it raises more questions about gates who
seems to be now making himself a martyr
for allegedly having paid a minor for
sex
very very strange when he did the tucker
carlson interview not last week but the
week before
he sort of strangely seemed to implicate
tucker and even raise new questions
denying that he ever paid for sex which
at the time was not even part of the
publicly known investigation just
it gets worse every time time after time
after time so
for now you know uh one one of the
really funny things
is in some way doesn't this invalidate
the q anon
conspiracy because q anon is a
conspiracy theory based on the idea
that donald trump was sent to fight an
imaginary
child sex trafficking ring run run by
democrats
if trump was eager to defend gates
despite child sex trafficking claims
it doesn't really sound like the type of
guy who would be fighting against
child sex trafficking that q anon
believes him to be
just a side note about yet another one
of these conflicts between these various
conspiracy theories
but despite trump not publicly
supporting matt gates
matt gates is saying that he still has
donald trump's
support so we're going to talk about
that after the break make sure
that you are following me on instagram
you can find me on instagram at
david.pacman
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going
is through patreon where you can pledge
as little as one dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow great perks and benefits
as well
read about them all right so let's sort
of close the loop on our coverage of the
matt gates situation i told you
uh last segment that uh donald trump had
to be talked out of publicly defending
matt gates because the believed
allegations against him are so
serious now in the next segment you will
see that matt gates is still claiming
that he has support from donald trump
but breaking this morning a report
from cnn that matt gates tried to meet
with donald trump and was denied
such a meeting it seems as though donald
trump has been
thoroughly convinced by his aides and
staffers that
matt gates is completely toxic right now
and actually this fits very much
within what we know about donald trump
and i'll i'll get into that in a moment
the report from cnn is that congressman
matt gates
facing a federal investigation into sex
trafficking allegations
recently was denied a meeting that he
tried to get with donald trump at
trump's mar-a-lago estate
as trump and allies continue to distance
from the florida
congressmen two people familiar with the
matter
say that uh gates tried to schedule a
visit
with donald trump after it was revealed
that he was being investigated
but the request was rejected by aides
close to donald trump who as i mentioned
to you in the previous segment
are telling trump don't stick your neck
out for this guy
don't defend matt gates harlan hill
who is a spokesman for gates is denying
it and saying no such meeting
was requested and that actually gates
was welcomed
to trump doral this weekend and didn't
try to meet with donald trump
now my instinct is that this is of
course if you are
if you're matt gates you request the
meeting
through staff and if it's rejected the
staff
simply deny having requested it and if
you're matt gates
you can accurately say i never requested
anything so if you say well how do i
adjudicate the differences between the
claims that are being made
it's it's quite obvious to me that uh
the this is exactly what
the way it would work if indeed matt
gates quietly tried to get the meeting
and it was uh
rejected uh cnn writes that the
interference by trump's aides
signals that gates is increasingly
isolated
as he weathers a potentially
career-ending scandal just
months after he offered to leave his job
to join trump's impeachment defense team
comedically gates joining the
impeachment defense team
may have been more substantive as far as
you know like saturday night live
writers
are concerned uh but this may actually
be a much more interesting
sort of going down in flames for uh matt
gates now you'll also remember
that last week it was revealed and
reported that matt gates tried to get a
blanket preemptive pardon from donald
trump
at the end of donald trump's presidency
that has also been denied by donald
trump trump claiming
gates did not ask me for a pardon again
with all of these things
it's possible that gates staffers went
to trump staffers and said would this
work
trump staffers would have said he's not
going to do that and as far as trump
knows
it was never an official request and so
nobody's really lying
but the spirit of this is that gates did
want
the pardon that's often you know in
political speak
the way this is all orchestrated is to
have that plausible deniability trump
can say
i was never asked to pardon him and that
can be true
while it can also be true that gates
directed staff to feel out
trump staff as to whether it's something
that might be possible
um now the the other kind of question
about the meeting being denied between
gates and trump
is that gates was at this event in
florida
and although he didn't meet privately
with trump
you would think that that has some
meaning that he was still sort of
allowed
to participate at the other on the other
end
what can trump really even do for gates
at this point i mean it seems that at
this point the story is so
out of the bag either republicans big
picture
are just going to start ignoring it and
matt gates will be able to survive this
and won't have to resign
or gates is basically going to be done
for but beyond just repeating the same
lies
that gates is telling i don't really
know what trump can do for gates at this
point in time
when trump was president lying about
himself to some degree worked in another
sense it didn't because trump lost
and he lost the house for republicans
and he lost the senate but it at least
kept trump
afloat amid some scandals
trump as a former president telling lies
in defense of matt gates
it's not really clear to me that it
would do very much now one last thought
on this before we move on to what matt
gates is actually saying about all of
these things
um loyalty is a one-way street
with donald trump matt gates was
completely loyal
to a sort of disgusting sycophantic
level
during trump's presidency but gates is
no longer
useful to donald trump once you're no
longer useful to trump or you have your
own problems trump tosses you aside like
he's done
to so many people in his life eventually
it's always just a matter of time so
that's the latest from trump
let's now look at some of the very
strange things that matt gates said
so after donald trump was reportedly
talked out of defending matt gates
after donald trump reportedly rejected a
meeting with matt gates
matt gates spoke over the weekend at
some kind of
very bizarre event called the save
america summit
and despite donald trump having to be
talked out of defending matt gates
matt gates is claiming that donald trump
still supports him
gates now believed to be the target of
multiple investigations
various different crimes including
possibly child sex trafficking across
state borders
gates is saying i have the support of
trump he also mentions he has the
support of jim jordan and marjorie
taylor-green two of the most unhinged
republican members of congress right now
uh let's take a listen we have your back
that is the sentiment i have heard from
thousands of americans
at restaurants walking through public
parks sometimes
just out on the street in emails online
donations
and i can't tell you how much it means
to me this past week has been full
of encouragement from president trump
marjorie taylor greene and jim jordan
to the maga nation that shares so much
love
so let me assure you i have not yet
begun to fight
for the country i love and for the
nation that i know benefits
from america first principles i'm built
for the battle
and i'm not going anywhere matt gates is
talking like he's a victim here
he's talking like he is the one that
uh everybody else is being unfair to
he's making himself out to be
almost like a martyr of some kind over
being
investigated for trafficking kids and
paying for prostitutes and who knows
what else
it's becoming a horror movie in sum
total
then truly martyring himself weirdly
comparing himself here to george
h.w bush this is completely insane
listen to this clip even suggesting that
the deep state
may be after him when he accepted the
1988
republican nomination for president
george herbert walker bush said
i'm a quiet man and i hear
the quiet people of our country will
america first
is not a quiet movement and i am not a
quiet man
i may be a canceled man in some corners
i may even be a wanted man by the deep
state
but i hear the millions of americans who
feel forgotten
canceled ignored marginalized
and targeted i draw confidence knowing
that the silent majority is growing
louder by the day
in this great country and so i welcome
to our movement the libertarians the
populists the different
the canceled anyone who can rally around
our inclusive
america first agenda what silent
majority is matt gates talking about a
silent majority that supports child
sex trafficking like what what is what
is this guy on
uh what planet is this guy on and it
almost doesn't matter
but just so that you know matt gates
also falsely claimed at this event
that trump won the 2020 election so
gates is still doing all the same
sucking up to trump
trump seems to completely be rejecting
matt gates because gates is not useful
to him anymore
saying he's a canceled man you know
being canceled and being held
accountable for crimes you may have
committed
those are very very very different
things and and that is really some spin
i mean think about that we don't have
millions of incarcerated criminals in
this country
we have millions of canceled men in
prison that's the new term
for there are consequences to your
actions he's being investigated for
paying
kids maybe for maybe having paid kids
for sex
and he's framing himself as a hero
because law enforcement is investigating
him it's almost more
alt-right than it is trumpian you know
trump is known for
skating by endless allegations of all
sorts
his supporters don't idolize trump for
the things trump is accused of they
either just don't believe the things
trump is accused of
or they ignore them and say they don't
matter gates is almost
going alt-right and that the alt-right
actually will make
heroes out of people who did or are
accused of having done
really horrible things so these are very
strange times we live in and for me the
most important context is
it's april of 2021 uh we're 19 months
from the midterm elections
what happens to the republican party in
19 months
if this type of insanity continues i
have a voicemail today
that is it's an important issue that for
some reason people think i'm unwilling
to address
i'm very willing to address it our
voicemail number is 2192 david p
and this has to do with covet deaths
take a listen to this
hey david is troll man the
anti-intellectual here so i got a
question for you um
new jersey new york and massachusetts
had the highest
death rate per capita from copenhagen
right yet they had pretty restrictive
measures
lockdowns and all that yeah florida
was pretty low on that list i wonder why
are are the scientists or is the science
actually that accurate
it seems like it's not i'd like to hear
your thoughts yeah this has nothing to
do with science being or not being
accurate so as a count
the argument from troll man the
anti-intellectual is
you've got these blue states blue states
claim to be better on covid but new york
new jersey and massachusetts have some
of the highest death rates per capita
what's the explanation well
you for the first thing is you have to
think is there a counter example well
yeah vermont and maine
are very blue states and they have some
of the lowest death rates per capita
this goes back to uh you know look at
death rates per capita in the last
six months and you see a very different
picture and
unfortunately some of the best connected
places
that have both lots of uh conferences
and and uh people that come from all
over the world
for meetings and direct flights to the
early sources of the virus
got hit the hardest in deaths per capita
because they had
some of the earliest outbreaks before we
were better at treating isolating
and containing the coronavirus the
the perfect examples are boston where
one of the earliest kind of spreader
events was a conference
that included people from asia and
europe
in boston that became sort of an early
spreader event
and seeded the virus in the boston area
new york and you and and boston
with direct flights to you know italy
multiple cities in china france
germa you know the places where the
virus came to the u.s
from you had months of flights non-stop
flights back and forth from boston
almost the exact same thing with new
york and new jersey
new york with jfk airport new jersey
just over the bridge
uh what is it nine miles from from
manhattan with newark airport
non-stop flights everywhere and
huge conferences etc so there is really
no
set rule mississippi has one of the
highest per capita death rates it's not
because mississippi has non-stop flights
all over the world to places that were
early covet infected places
uh mississippi is high because they
didn't do a damn thing
uh different places have different
explanations
now the massachusetts death rate for
example is tiny i believe that
three people died on saturday and eight
people died on sunday
extremely low death rate now unlucky
new york new jersey massachusetts to
have been hit early
with almost uncontrolled spread with
non-stop flights to the hot spot so
you know there's no one's one-stop shop
answer if any anybody's looking for
uh a one-stop shop answer there really
isn't one but it is interesting to look
at per capita death and case rates over
the last six months
rather than at the very beginning when
we knew very little
great bonus show for for you today we
will talk about what's going on with
prison inmates and covet release
some maybe disturbing things we will
talk about the flop of a white lives
matter rally
and we will talk about the chinese covet
vaccine which seems to have low
efficacy all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show get instant access
by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman